hey everyone i'm jojo stiwa and right
now i am here with buzzfeed to talk
about my first
the first album that i ever bought would
probably be a hannah montana album when
my mom and i come out to california when
i was little she we would drive from
palm springs where
myself my mom and my grandparents lived
and we would drive out to l.a and that
could be like a two-hour drive and we
would listen to the hannah montana
soundtrack the whole way i know every
song it was our favorite thing to listen
to favorite song from hannah montana he
could be the one but i like to replace
it and say she could be the one it's my
favorite thing to do first a-list celeb
that followed you meghan trainor is
actually the first a-list celeb that
followed me she
is the coolest human ever now she's like
literally my sister my family my best
friend i was actually at the kids choice
awards and she was the first ever a-list
celebrity that i went up to and she was
like oh my god you're jojo's cy like i
love you oh first big purchase so when i
was on dance moms every kid on the bus
ride the very first week had an imac and
i didn't and i felt like a loser so i
got my first paycheck and boom took it
to the apple store and got me an imac
first time you realized you were famous
yet to have it uh i don't know i don't
like to look at myself as i'm famous
when i came out i was like whoa
when miley cyrus knew who i was that was
a big eye-opener for me i heard her
music i'm like a huge miley cyrus fan
and where i was rehearsing i heard her
music playing next door but there was no
vocal so i was like oh my god it's her
band the next day i heard her vocal and
i was like oh my god she's in there so i
told my choreographer it was like our
second to last day of rehearsals and i
was like richie i cannot leave this area
right now i was like if i come back into
rehearsals i was like i'm gonna miss
when she leaves her room and i just need
to see her even if i don't do anything i
just need to see her so finally i'm
waiting outside for like two hours fine
i was like all right i'm just gonna go
poke my head in the room say hi say i
love you and run away
and i did that and as i went in
she was coming out with her mom
and my heart dropped i mean i
sank and she was like oh my god you're
jojo right and i was like
i don't know am i like i couldn't even
think first bts memory that comes to
mind from filming the j team when we
were filming
change me which is one of the finale
numbers in the movie it's one of the
finale songs we were all so
loopy and out of it and i like to use
the term punch drunk we were just all
like oh my god we're on hour 16 of
hearing this song now it's the best
number in the film but it was really
funny my first celebrity crush oh
boy please zac efron miley cyrus demi i
did i did it's my girlfriend went to
their concert she says that that was her
gay awakening for me though it was
watching the video of that performance i
was like i like that a little too much i
like that a little too much first
impression of my girlfriend i actually
thought my brother and her were like
kind of talking and so i was like oh
jayden's talking to girls and now i'm
like
ill but i don't know i think my first
impression was like oh she looks cool
i'm scared of her like
first embarrassing moment on stage oh i
mean i've had plenty when i was a dancer
but i'm gonna go when i was on tour i
fell on stage that was pretty
embarrassing i've ripped my pants 450
times every time i perform guarantee
every time i perform i rip my pants it's
like a known thing i rip every single
pair that i own but i think the most
embarrassing would have to be when i was
in dublin ireland and i wear a side
ponytail bow and in the middle of my
performance i have like a fake ponytail
that has a bunch of colors on it and
extra hair and it just starts to like
slide out and i was like oh god for me
there's so much to look at on my stage
the odds of somebody looking at my hair
flying out is zero so for me i just have
to pretend like it's not happening first
big date ooh what's funny is my
girlfriend and i we dated for like five
and a half months and before we actually
went on our first date we went on our
first date when we were in disney we
actually went to the park together in
orlando florida and that was really fun
that was our first date first crazy or
funny fan interaction one time i was on
this cruise ship and this girl just came
up to me and stood right in front of me
and was just like
bug-eyed looking at me and i was like hi
and she was just like
i was like okay and she was
blank the whole time that one was really
funny first hard lesson you learned
living in the public eye obviously
there's haters and that was really hard
to deal with when i was little uh it
still could be hard to deal with now it
was hard it was hard to take at first
and i just was confused on it and i
didn't get why
why somebody wanted to be mean it didn't
make sense to me first impression of
chloe feynman's impersonation of you i
was honored i thought it was beautiful i
really did when i saw it i was like that
is cool you know how many people can say
that they've done an impersonation of
them on snl a lot but it's really cool
that i can too i would host snl tomorrow
if they asked me to absolutely all right
everybody well that was my first thank
you so much for watching make sure you
stream the j team on paramount plus
peace
[Music]
you